Congratulations!
You’ve just started your new job at the
SCP Foundation as a Junior Researcher.
We hope you survive long enough to retire
and collect your Foundation pension - but
you’ve got a lot to learn before you can
even think about that.
You’re here to find out more about some
of the most mysterious entities known to man,
and the Foundation depends on you to do your
job right, or the world might not see tomorrow
- but hey, no pressure.
You’re gonna hear a lot of new terminology
on the job.
Big, scary words like “Apollyon” and “Thaumatology.”
And, of course, “Euclid” and “Keter”,
the two most common containment classifications.
Today, we’re gonna answer a question that’s
been on a lot of people’s minds: What do
these classifications actually mean, and what’s
the difference between them?
First, it must be noted that these classes
don’t have as much to do with danger as
you may think.
Instead, object classes are all about how
difficult an anomaly is to contain.
And we’re going to take you on a crash course
of each of them, and provide some examples
so you can broaden your idea of what exactly
“Euclid”, “Keter”, and all the other
classes of anomalies can be.
Of course, while Euclid and Keter are perhaps
the best known object classes, they aren’t
the only ones.
Just below them, in terms of severity, is
the “Safe” Class.
It may be every guard and D-Class’s dream
to get assigned to “Safe” SCPs, but this
classification doesn’t mean that the anomaly
in question is harmless.
It does mean that they are easy to contain
though, often requiring very few resources
or certain specific activation mechanisms.
For example, SCP-507, the unwilling dimension
hopper, is fully cooperative with Foundation
containment protocols, earning him the “Safe”
class.
SCP-662, the Butler’s Hand Bell, while capable
of extreme violence, doesn’t activate unless
someone rings it, making it “safe” to
store.
And of course, SCP-999, the Tickle Monster,
earned its “Safe” rating by essentially
wanting to keep Foundation staff pleased at
every turn and requiring virtually nothing
in the way of containment.
Euclid comes next.
This class actually has the widest scope of
any object class under Foundation control,
and the grand majority of objects fall under
this banner.
Unlike Safe class anomalies, Euclid anomalies
require greater resources to keep contained.
The “Euclid” Classification can also mean
that containment isn’t always reliable,
and is often given due to either a lack of
knowledge about the anomaly or there being
some degree of inherent unpredictability.
“Unpredictable” is really the key word
when it comes to Euclid SCPs.
Anomalies that are either autonomous, meaning
they can move on their own; sentient, meaning
that they are capable of thought; or Sapient,
meaning they are particularly intelligent,
almost always automatically fall into the
Euclid Class.
This is because anything that moves or thinks
on its own is capable of surprising and unpredictable
behavior.
Notwithstanding certain exceptions like the
aforementioned Tickle Monster.
This brings us to Keter.
In the simplest terms, you could describe
Keter class anomalies as “Euclid but worse.”
Again, this has nothing to do with how violent
or dangerous the anomaly is, merely how difficult
it is to contain.
Keter Class anomalies often require extensive
resources to fully contain.
Containment methods are also often extra thorough
and complex, though when it comes to a Keter
Class anomaly, there’s no guarantee the
methods will be one hundred percent effective.
There are a number of reasons an SCP can slip
into Keter territory including, but not limited
to, extreme aggression in its frequent escape
attempts, existing in large numbers over a
wide area, and having anomalous abilities
that make them particularly difficult to contain,
like teleportation or the ability to walk
through walls.
To better explain this, Foundation researchers
have devised a simple method known as the
“Locked Box Test.”
If you were to leave an item inside a locked
box and stop supervising it, and it’s still
there when you get back, then that item is
probably “Safe.”
If you leave an item inside a locked box without
supervision and you’re not sure what exactly
will happen, then it’s probably “Euclid.”
If you leave an item inside a locked box without
supervision and it easily breaks free, then
you likely have a “Keter” object on your
hands.
Or rather, did, before it broke out and ran
off.
Before we go any further, it’s worth briefly
mentioning that there are two other primary
object classes that cover most SCPs that aren’t
under the “Safe”, “Euclid”, and “Keter”
banners.
These are “Thaumiel” and “Neutralized.”
Thaumiel anomalies are SCPs that are used
to contain other SCPs - such as SCP-3000,
the legendary Amnestic-producing Anantashesha.
Neutralized anomalies are objects that have
either lost their anomalous qualities or been
straight-up destroyed.
A good example being SCP-1762, the cardboard
box which used to contain the land of Fantasy.
But back to Euclid and Keter: What are some
good examples of Euclid and Keter class anomalies
in containment right now?
Let’s take a look at some of the Foundation’s
most iconic Euclid-classes first.
Kicking things off, we have SCP-096, also
known as the Shy Guy.
We all know and fear this self-conscious,
serial-killing monster that murders anything
that sees its face.
As you already know, when someone sees the
face of the Shy Guy, nothing can stand in
its way on its quest to utterly destroy them.
The monster has not only proven successful
in causing mass casualty events, it’s also
pretty much indestructible and has shown that
it’s able to tear its way out of containment
with ease.
So, you may be wondering, why is the Shy Guy
Euclid and not Keter?
While it may surprise you to hear this, SCP-096
is actually closer to “Safe” than “Keter.”
The monster may be incredibly dangerous when
its rage state is activated, but it’s proven
fairly easy for the Foundation to control
this activation.
The only times that 096 has breached containment
is when photographs of its face have been
found out in the world, but as long as the
Foundation can prevent people from seeing
its face, it poses no real risk of containment
breach.
The very fact that the Foundation can’t
know for sure how many photos of it are out
there adds an element of unpredictability
to its containment, and that is why - despite
being incredibly scary and dangerous - 096
is firmly Euclid.
Next, another Euclid anomaly that needs no
introduction: SCP-173, also known as The Sculpture.
This nasty piece of modern art has given workers
at the Foundation many a sleepless night thanks
to its terrifying tendency to snap the necks
of anyone who isn’t looking at it.
This is a creature so scary that even SCP-682
feels uncomfortable around it.
Much like SCP-096, 173 has also proved nigh
impossible to kill, and in a containment breach,
it’s been known to stack up bodies like
it was judgment day.
So, why just Euclid rather than Keter?
Once again, it all comes down to the Foundation
understanding just how 173 ticks.
As everyone knows by now, 173 is paralyzed
whenever someone is looking at it.
As a result, the Foundation has been able
to devise containment methods that center
around keeping 173 constantly observed.
The reason it’s Euclid rather than safe
is that, while quite reliable, this method
is also somewhat time and resource intensive.
And as with anything that requires a high
degree of human involvement, the potential
for human error is always there.
And finally, in our rundown of famous Euclid
class objects, we have SCP-3008, more broadly
known as the infinite Ikea.
This sinister retail giant is a pocket dimension
hiding within an Ikea superstore, leading
to what seems to be an infinite furniture
warehouse, filled with scary, faceless creatures
known as The Staff.
Hundreds or perhaps even thousands of people
have become trapped in SCP-3008, and it may
even connect to other dimensions.
This is one place where you really, really
don’t want to get stuck while shopping for
a new piece of furniture.
But it’s still Euclid.
Why?
Well, because - to the best of our knowledge
- there’s only one gateway into 3008’s
pocket dimension inside our reality, and the
Foundation has that specific site on lockdown.
While there are still things we don’t know
about SCP-3008, the Foundation has been able
to secure and contain the entrance.
It’s Euclid rather than “Safe” because
this entrance still needs to be patrolled
regularly to ward off any Staff attempting
to escape, and prevent further victims from
entering, which is a low risk but resource-heavy
job.
Next up is Keter Class.
First, we have the terrifying SCP-682, also
known as the Hard to Destroy Reptile.
Anyone who’s seen our videos on this nasty
creature knows that it really, really lives
up to that name.
682 may not be the most dangerous SCP - especially
with cosmic monsters like the Scarlet King
and the Devourer of Worlds out there - but
it’s one of the most hardy, thanks to its
incredible adaptive abilities.
Because of the way 682 adapts to pretty much
any threat, it’s virtually impossible to
attack it the same way twice.
However, if being violent and indestructible
was all it took to become a Keter class anomaly,
the Shy Guy would be right there with it.
There are two key factors that push 682 into
Keter territory: Its incredibly high intelligence
and the fact it reacts unpredictably to all
external stimuli.
Because of its intelligence, 682 is able to
actively scheme to escape containment, something
it does with such regularity that the Foundation
is constantly trying to terminate it.
And because of its adaptive abilities, its
behavior in response to containment is often
nigh impossible to predict.
As a result of all this, 682 is a complete
nightmare to keep locked up, making it Keter.
Next, a Keter Class anomaly that’s not quite
as well known and not nearly as ferocious:
SCP-3663, also known as The Tunnel Monster
or the Cardboard Box Monster.
This entity is as scary as it is incredibly
sad - he was once a normal little boy, playing
in an abandoned industrial area with his friends.
He had built himself a crude monster costume
out of cardboard boxes, but through anomalous
means, this costume bonded with the little
boy, turning his organs into cardboard and
twine.
Now, it manifests in pipes and tunnels across
the country, approaching nearby humans and
causing paranoia and fear.
It’ll then grab his victims, and transport
them elsewhere.
Leaving them unconscious and afraid, but otherwise
unharmed.
Clearly, we’re not looking at an anomaly
even close to being as dangerous and deadly
to SCP-682, but it’s still very much Keter.
Why?
Because the teleporting ability inherent to
SCP-3663 makes it incredibly difficult to
consistently contain, along with its inherent
distrust of Foundation personnel.
The Foundation have yet to devise a truly
effective containment method for 3663 and
its teleporting antics, so Keter class is
where it remains, despite being mostly benign.
And finally, SCP-1000, aka Bigfoot.
This is one of the few anomalies that genuinely
holds the moral high ground over the Foundation,
on account of them formerly being an incredibly
advanced species almost wiped out by humanity
in the past.
Now, the Foundation is feeding everyone the
lie that even looking at one of these creatures
can result in death - even though it can’t.
The reality is that the Foundation hopes to
keep SCP-1000 suppressed, fearing that if
they ever regained their former glory, they
would surely oppress humanity just as humanity
had oppressed them.
Even though, once again, it doesn’t appear
that SCP-1000 has any such malicious intentions.
So why are these abnormally large and abnormally
intelligent apes Keter Class?
Once again, it all comes down to two facts
tipping the classification scales, and in
this case those are population and dispersion.
There are a lot of these creatures out there,
especially across North America, and the fact
they appear in forests all across the country
makes it incredibly difficult for the Foundation
to keep a lid on them.
Seeing as a civilian simply seeing an SCP-1000
specimen constitutes a containment breach,
these happen frequently, especially if you
run in cryptid and conspiracy circles and
are out actually looking to meet one.
That brings us to the end of our crash course
on Euclid and Keter class anomalies.
We hope you’ve enjoyed your stay, and managed
to survive all the strange and horrific entities
we’ve covered.
Let us know if you enjoyed this video in the
comments and want to see more of the ins and
outs of the SCP Foundation’s classification
system explained.
But for now you’re finally ready to start
your research role at the SCP Foundation - just
make sure you’ve got your last will and
testament written before your first day.
Now check out “SCP Chaos Insurgency Explained”
and “SCP - 001 - Which Is The Real 001?”
for more of the SCP Foundation’s most top
secret files!